because you have no respect for us, for
the Catholics and the
Orthodox, right? Anyway, here you go.
Here's the final shot. Now, watch here.
I reached out to him again last
night. Now, to show you what kind of son
of Satan he is. Look what he does again.
He again misqu butchers a passage of
scripture. Scripture. Look, 2 Timothy
2:24:25. How many times do I have to
correct these guys for misquing
scripture, quoting verses out of
context, butchering scripture? And how
many times must this run from me when I
call him out to come on Streamyard
instead of showing up, he hides. So now
since he doesn't want to join my
Streamyard, I now reached out to Donnie
as well as reason believe to provide a
neutral platform. So let's play it
because I'm done with this. Donnie will
reach out reach back to me and reason
belief will reach out to me see if he
accepted because he's too scared to come
on my streamyard which is why he wants
to hide behind is we're going to do it
on a neutral platform here guys and I
want to hear from this stick figure
again but here hey
uh I just contacted Danny Donnie from
standing for truth tomorrow I'm going to
give you one more chance to come live
when I set it up I don't know when
because my kids are here I'm going to
send you the link
If you then excuses to
hide, I'm going to be showing these
messages and playing these videos. And I
just sent Donnie a message standing for
truth to contact you because I know
you're scared to do it on his platform
to have a discussion. You need to step
down and go do something else. Hopefully
repent, but then Donniey's going to
reach out to you and then you have no
excuses. So appeals to sympathy. A guy
who calls Catholics and Orthodox false
Christians. A guy who says that they're
pretty much
idolattors because they believe in a
false gospel and they believe in our
nation of saints and Mary's perpetual
virginity now wants to play nice. And
brethren, I don't know if you see this.
Paul warned that the agents of Satan
will appear as apostles of
righteousness. They will appear humble
and spiritual just like Satan appears as
an angel of light. I read it yesterday.
Don't be deceived because those of you
who have been exposed to
narcissism, if you guys have been
exposed to narcissism, you know this is
classic narcissistic behavior, right?
And it seems like narcissism is now much
more widespread so that everyone has
some form of narcissism. May the Lord
Jesus Christ purge me of that, purge and
purify, cleanse us of that for the glory
of Jesus Christ. Here, reason believe
you reached out to him, right? Yeah, one
of you. That's why I had you both. Now,
notice what narcissists do. You guys
know it, right? May the Lord Jesus save
us from
any right state of narcissism. If I am,
may God save me from it. They will
attack you. They will mock you. They
will insult you. And then when you put
these dogs in their place and muscle
them, then they play victim and nice guy
or nice girl and vilify you. Who started
this war? Me too. I was brother. I was
in a marriage within our sisters 10
years. This war. Who attacked us? Who
accused Catholics and Orthodox of having
a false gospel and that they're not
Christians, but pretty much idolatry?
Was it me? Was it us? And how many times
must I correct his butchering of
scripture? He butchered Titus 1. He
butchered 2 Timothy 2:24-25, which I
addressed. So now notice I called him
out and he goes, "Let's be nice." Well,
by the way, for the
record just to call out his
lie. Just call out the
lie. Go watch my debates when I have a
professional debate discussion. Go
watch. Do I attack or insult? No. I
demolish, pulverize, destroy the lies
and the blasphemies of the blasphemers,
but I don't insult them. So he's hiding,
playing victim. But this is satanic cuz
narcissism is of the devil, not our
brother. When he accuses Catholics,
Orthodox of being pretty much false
Christians, preaching false gospel,
meaning you are going to hell. That's
not your
brother. So notice what I said. Be ready
for when I go live. Your
butchering of second Timothy 2 20. I was
supposed to put
256, right? Okay, Mommy, come on in.
Hold on. I don't say it. Someone can see
you. Remember, we're going to be leaving
in a couple hours, right? The rest. All
right. So, you had a good time.
And then I told him I'm going to reach
out to Donnie, right? All right. Well,
because I don't want him to use an
excuse that he's afraid that I'll cut
him off. All right. Reason, belief.
Reached out to him. He's got the
receipts. He's going to be a nut. We're
going to have inter. Remember the
discussion I had with JD Martin? Go
watch. Was I rude, nasty to him? No. I
didn't let him run off on tangents. And
now here's the receipts. Now I've given
you
documentation. He is not your brother.
And I'm gonna let Donnie or Reason
Believe set it up. I don't want to hear
from him. I'm warning you guys. Stop
sending me videos of people who are
jokes. But if you're a joke, not saying
the regulars, you know you are. Here our
brother just sending him. Here he goes.
Right. And now here I sent this to
Donnie. You ready? Here it is. See it?
He just sent it to me. That's reason
belief. He sent him this
message. He sent them this message. Now,
that's one. It's now documented. Can
slander Catholics and Orthodox out of
his ignorance who thinks he's he knows
the Bible. Now, watch. What did I say to
Donnie? Here, let's give you the
receipts. Let's go here. Let's go here.
Here's the voicemail I sent him, right?
Let's find
it. Where is it, man? Dude, come on.
Donnie. Donnie, I sent you a voicemail,
Donnie. Donnie, why you give me
problems, dude? There you go. We're
going to play it. And now we're going to
begin. Now, I'm just going to focus on
I'm just going to focus on
justification. I have about two and a
half hours to teach. Let's make it
fruitful. No more with this. I'm not
going to block him because reason belief
and Donnie will offer a neutral platform
here. Listen,
receipts. Donnie, can you do me a favor?
I'm going to send you the link to this
guy, neededgod.net, whom I call
needlasticsurgery.net. I've been
challenging him. I want to have a
discussion, not a moderate debate, a
discussion where we have interactive
ongoing
discussion for as long as it takes on
his view of what justifying faith is.
So, I don't want to use an excuse to
run. Would you set it up? You can
moderate it. He can we can do opening
statements. He can speak 10 minutes. I
speak 10. Whatever it is. But I want
interactive discussion. Him and I going
at it. No time limits where it's opening
rebuttals, closing statements, you
know, interaction,
cross-examination. So, could you set it
up for me, brother? I'll give you his
link because this make excuses to run.
There you go. Yeah. I don't want to hide
behind time limits just like in debates
you have what they call cross-
examination like I did with JD Martin. I
want it can be two three hours. Paul did
not respect false brethren who butchered
the
gospel. All right. They're saying you
are false Christians. They're saying you
belong to Satan. They're saying you are
the ones who don't know Jesus. They're
what are you not
getting? All right. Now with that said,
we have the receipts.
All